for each of the things that i have lost
i have been put in contact
with absolutely
marvelous people that i never would have
encountered otherwise people like you
that i've never met
in person but you and i are capable of
having this conversation and you know
look i wouldn't know that you existed
but for the fact that we had
been thrown out of the same academy
at different times for different crimes
and uh
i guess
this is the thing i hope people will
understand is that the horror
of what is happening of us losing track
of who we are and what we've learned and
what it means
is only matched by the unusual
fact of the dissidents
being driven together and discovering
each other in a way that would have been
impossible until
i don't know
50 years ago
right and
there is a tremendous
amount of
solace in discovering the high quality
people who have said no
and um have been ejected and are now
just becoming aware of
the parallel others i find something
um as
dystopian as this moment is i find
something very hopeful
in uh in all of the marvelous people who
who have been forced to the surface by
it
it's a beautiful kind of poetic irony
in some sense it's also it's very sad to
me when i hear people who have been hurt
by what's happened over the last couple
of years by the mandates or whatever
social ostracization or whatever that
they speak as though um
sadness and badness in life are
inevitable as a result of these things
as though
and you know that's coupled with
language like i'm i'm forced to make a
certain choice i'm forced to
abide by the mandates or whatever but i
think
you know one of the things that that
that the story that you are telling
shows is that
we can be
coerced we can be manipulated we can
face pressures from all sides that make
us feel like our
scope of choice is not what it was
but we cannot be forced to be other than
what we want to be in our souls
[Music]